what's up full podcast what's our full
podcast welcome to the word so full
podcast we're here every week live now
on youtube.com slash ATC if you're
watching this live or listening live on
youtube.com what's up boo we got a 300
toy right here watching will be a
tourist
Lisa Esparza right here what's up fool
first of all man I just want to say
thank you everybody for listening and
this I'm gonna be little dates
December 7th through 9th I'll be at the
Tempe improv in Tempe Arizona December 7
8 & 9
that's Friday Saturday Sunday and those
shows are almost well there's about 3/4
sold all those shows so they're gonna
sell out before the weekend so there you
go hurry up people
hurry yeah we ain't had insurance
property Ontario California this show
man you better find a scalper now our
Tarot improv December 27 through 30 year
I think there's still a lot of tickets
cuz we just added that show but sunday
was almost sold out Friday and Saturday
there's like 10 20 tickets each show
Sunday one show so far so if you have a
girlfriend or a wife and it's her
birthday
you try surprised it by taking it over
there and making her stand in line for
one hour and then buying a ticket for a
comedy show it ain't gonna happen
let me sound out but let me tell where
that that could have happened that could
happen anytime in Toledo or stress
factory I'll going up to the door or or
last week at the funny bone where with
that at the buffalo helium buffalo that
played bet you could have walked in
there
30 minutes into the show with 30 people
and I would appreciate it what's up boo
so get those tickets man don't delay
also December 31st New Year's Eve Denver
Colorado Paramount Theater be there
people get those tickets
which are a move bass or you know people
in the area who has that on Facebook
with not on no social media and they
know who I am let them know shout out
the window shut out the window ban yell
it out
and if you could do that appreciate it
I'm pretty sure man if if I see you or
Instagram telling people a flippin part
is gonna be in there you better go or
you make up your own you start promoting
by yourself man you know we could kick
it Bridgeport Connecticut was full
Bridgeport a bit the Bridgeport
Connecticut stress factory January 3rd
through the 5th house in a big by the
water it's gonna yeah cuz you're gonna
be what by the water in Connecticut that
windchill factor it's it comes right off
the waters [ __ ] cold January 26 I'm
coming to a Turlock California don't ask
me where that is I thought oh that Iraq
by a prison I think it's above below sub
demons above Sacramento to the right and
to the east I bet you they'll be at
Erlich gangnam where you from
we ought to lock you turn lock 13 I
think Turlock is gonna sell out before
that comes 14 surprisingly a lot of
people who live in that area Crips
they want to laugh shut up to this hat
ROG of new hat yeah man and head get
some headgear in Buffalo's cold we
lucked out man now we're by our hotel
was left to the new era store I don't
think they have a new era store over
here or do they I've never seen one no
lids right yeah that was a headquarters
yeah so it's all live over here we have
lids and you buy hats we say you know
like baseball hats
ya know that's right you put up through
the back and people wear hats
you'll picture where you were many hats
you know in your job for that the door
intimate they were spayed dog I couldn't
stop [ __ ] laughing oh my god died hey
I hope you started your first your first
show you started off at her please
I was in Arizona car greasy Tony's and I
died yes man he doesn't like this is
what he wanted
it's not like I would let her baby silly
but you go to the third power man but
it's bad he ends up with five he gives
up they were staying three goofy ass
joke to say hey I say this hey it's fun
you can throw it at you and you know
stuff right you can [ __ ] you you have
it huh you notice that you act hook you
know
and then his uh his his party gets
thrown off but he said he goes oh you
did it just to like add stuff like oh
you like oh you mean we she told you
there's to be a sandwich shop run across
different appear prom right I the rubric
does about the hater of [ __ ] back in
the days when you through the improv and
then get a sandwich you know like that
do you just live out here like cars it
was just read about the cars goes should
ask you this question I asked you
greasy Tony's ain't around anymore L
know places bomb the secret was the
grease Joe dealer throw the big sandwich
bro man what's up fool so yeah bad so
that's what we're talking about which is
a new era the place and they had like so
many hats like a Dodger hats that I
haven't seen like real good Dodger hats
whatever I was real big and they had to
UM it felt like um for cherry skin
terrycloth the big outlay what it was
made out of yeah it really has that you
like I like that one that looked like a
belt buckle I was cool duh Elia
Dodger 1 oh yes that was a great hat
Lisa there was a Dodger hat and a head
of our late logo right here kind of like
the one that uh batter one it was gold
cause it it's a garage I saw it but
actually that hat bad you can wear that
whole plate and psycho Tony picture the
glare so we were in Buffalo we get there
in this coat
no not that cool but our look the next
day fart ago it was all white I didn't
think I thought they're still gonna shut
down now therefore prepare the rail
blankets now but that kind of stuff will
kill at us who killed Alice kill cops I
was so nervous for you guys because
Buffalo's my review is like for me to
know I've been to Chicago in January
yeah like snow the like Buffalo when I
lived in New York like we got you know
snow and it was nasty you have to you
know and I grew up in Ohio in Colorado a
ton of snow but Buffalo is traditionally
like the first place to get hit every
year by some nor'easter and it's like
1218 inches of snow something ridiculous
and I was just afraid I was crossing my
fingers all weekend that you guys aren't
gonna be snowed in our flight was I'm
done and um for for New Jersey ah that's
funny is it on my tracker it's still
acted like it was taken off and it
landed and everything and I knew you had
gotten rerouted so tracking both flights
yeah Toby had the news all like
instantaneously yeah and I even went up
onto a United Airlines website and
nothing like I thought it was just the
tracker wasn't showing it but United
didn't show it but we made it so glad we
made it
I'm glad you were going today early and
we still made as funny we still made it
like I'm time for our plane yeah well of
course could they change our plane yeah
and this morning we flew out home we
took a while we still get the too early
right we got to LA too early 20 minutes
I know that's a problem you guys get
there too early and we no luggage you're
gonna wait for them I took forever oh
man this photo went viral thing this guy
was arrested and I researched you know
we're talking about it on the phone on
Friday night for what this guy with a
big old neck oh yeah that fool it was
that photo went viral yeah I thought it
was Chris Paul angry bro I think it's I
think it's photoshopped first video of
him and it's big it's pretty it looks
awkward but it's it's real but the
original photo the people commenting on
it when we were eating it before you
left for Buffalo yeah some of these
comments are like I just personally
these people aren't even comedians but
they write a comment or they know how to
bag on something there's a roast people
this caught this cover this guy wrote
was so funny had 45,000 likes my
favorite want to think it ate three
Popeyes biscuits or could he Popeyes
biscuits with no drinkers no I was
thinking so strong he could he could
drink peanut butter there were a ton of
bags where they were we were doing bad
welcome to the next episode
but everybody was ever doing it still
but all those comments were already the
first one so far yeah Tom Segura post-op
Christina pea she posted a photo of Tom
Segura wearing wearing a jersey right a
football jersey
and sandals and something like a flannel
or flannel jacket and she I said
something about what he is this is that
and everybody wears a roll comment she
might copy I got 700 likes Florida style
I say he look like a gang a gang a gang
and drug intervention counselor
I should've brought you know the right
bird but nobody knows who he is I wasn't
yeah man he's like not really your
beautiful yet he's a Boston fan now huh
so I lay through the year they wanted
people that uh that they start off as a
certain thing and then little by little
they start wear a different hat and
finally start way the winners had you
gotta roll with the winner man kept it
Hollywood like a [ __ ]
but yeah he likes baseball he does
everything he something baseball
we're never really did coach open if his
son becomes a major leaguer he's gonna
be that that's gonna be a 13 you know
wherever that ends up where's he playing
in Kansas City College I don't know how
what's up fool well jiggle toy right
here man what are you wearing bro me a
sweater oh we know that
okay 5150 that's Corey Holcomb's
Internet show you got the internet quite
Hawkeye merchandise huh girl zero to get
it has emerged with Yemen our merch yeah
merchandise for chicks
what do they have hats he has this one
he has a couple other t-shirts it's
about that he had is a special on a
little necklace dude you just download
that [ __ ] talk about that that was cool
that was bad yeah it's like one of those
old school we have it right army yeah
you have it used to play it I put up
watch it but I mean I just have it like
collector's item style I mean I'm Corey
Corey Holcomb fan so yeah he said yeah
he couldn't get distribution for that
special it's like but the funny it's a
bucket said the funniest man on the
planet
shouts with joy Cody atop his we thought
we did really talk about the last time
but he's sure the trades would happen
Lisa well Fox
picked up well they didn't pick it up
they are developing a sitcom with him
and three arts and I forget the
production that means the three arts
management but it's not Dave Becky it's
that guy Josh there's two writers right
okay
I'm not sure who's writing on it I
haven't seen her the showrunner is but
that's gonna be mixture of flashbacks
him as an older guy now with his
daughter and trying to give her like
old-school wisdoms though so right now
they're I don't know what kind of deal
it was because it didn't mention it in
the article but he now is the process
where they start to write the script and
then by January you should know really
after the holidays you should know if
the network is gonna say yes to it or
not as a pilot to shoot it
and then amazed that they body and then
if it gets shot as a pilot there's they
still have to say yes to ordering
episodes so it's a separate several
steps of the process and it's lengthy
and it's frustrating but yeah it's great
if anybody deserves it as Joey that's
right yeah the Wolves broken marrow
commands
Kamath the fiery comic dog the partners
Joe going on man this was remind me of
Alonzo Bodden joke when I first started
doing stand-up comedy those fires that
gets back in 1995 he goes yeah there's a
lot of fires and out of the nose they're
gonna change the town to a couple of
Oaks sheriff Alonzo Bodden I died
[ __ ] hysterical yeah man what's up
throw the watch off so we have no guest
today one of the guests I'm not about
your shirt
[Laughter]
this is my dog hair shirt we had a dog
yes we are we have a new dog people was
a shout-out to squishy
she lost Grisha Rasheeda [ __ ] on our
floor right now link up with her rap
lovely Oh rescue is a page we follow on
Instagram and they help out there kind
of they have a rescue facility but they
also are liaison from people who work at
shelters and volunteer shelters who give
them a heads up when somebody comes in
it's a really bad case that might not
get adopted easily might get killed if
it's a kill shelter so they notify this
page and then they kind of put out the
call for hey there's this dog that needs
a foster or an adoptive family so she
came in it's about 15 days ago 16 days
ago yeah she was in the shelter for 13
days and but she was in bad shape she's
old for one she's kind of going blind a
little bit they think she's got like
mange which is now alopecia she had
mange for so long it turned into
alopecia which was you lose your hair
you know in patches so we're treating
all this stuff she's got she's got an
ear infection she's got all sorts of
stuff so she's got problems problem so a
fever special baths and then special
and everything and special soap and all
that stuff just like this mousse for her
feet because her feet are really bad
she's yeah man she came in well this has
been telling me that I'm she was just I
saw video of her what you just laying
there was like a bunch of other pitbulls
yeah they were in the yard
in the dog yard running every bit as
bathroom but they were jumping over her
and she would just wanted to lay there
and sleep like she's won the lady's
awesome
yeah she's old you know and they just
were jumping all over and like loud and
I would spelt bad and when I went to get
her like they're all in individual
closets but like the Venice Beach
bathroom it's all concrete you know
there's nothing just a water bowl that's
it like not a blanket nothing and she's
so bony that a lot of her like her
haunches like we're getting raw from
sitting on the concrete so much and I
feel so bad for her but I knew she
wouldn't be adopted because she's so old
so well we need an older dog cuz we have
the rabbits and we don't want a dog that
still chases after stuff and so far
she's seem like she hasn't met the
rabbits yeah because she's still sick so
got me making a dog joke it was like I'm
I don't know what it wasn't that funny
but but then he said too soon but then
it'll be funny if funnier if he woulda
rolled come on Donnie should have rode
out dogs go to heaven what a surfer yeah
but she's an old dog like she you know
like she's done with a chase like I just
changed the ice-cream man she has
changed no party ran into a couple
little dogs on the walk recently and she
just didn't even give him a second look
she just yanked her cape on yanking her
babies away from her baby sorry
yeah she does she looks very mopey very
sad so hopefully we took all my babies a
good life for a while
so he took her bath she stunk how he got
her I gave her a bath you get when your
father first he's more like dogs today
but she smells 20% better than she did
Wow but when I picked up the lady she
smelled like a homeless person that you
stand next to who's been homeless for a
while you know I think someone new I
heard another dog because we tell you
man I wanted to talk about last time but
when I did that [ __ ] live corner or I
would her acting class that's the same
way oh no no she's won like roses bro
I'm telling you bro because I felt like
you felt last week in your uh and your
lip right away that bad dog oh my god
dude I wish it was a dog smell she does
potent I know yeah I was bad but now I
brought my week I was ready for this one
I should have prepared you for that one
it's my bad but uh but dude oh geez oh
man that boys I smell like I hear
describing this way it's more like dirty
as vagina and [ __ ] together bro rap
together that's a Molly
maybe somebody stuffed a diaper or
something in there and you didn't know
about it but it's good food mix with pee
Oh whatever your favorite food is and
you know and I was giving the guy the
benefit of doubt I don't want to be like
stereotype you know okay we're both
brown people has to be one of us
right so I kept asking my bro up man I
like me I like been driving today oh
eight hours you know like ya know how
many people you've had in his car he
said like twelve and I said all right
you can man that was like oh it is si si
get a way to ask to get to him you know
maybe I've been home in three days or
you know I live in my car but I can't be
here
you don't look like the tiger like [ __ ]
in vagina that's what you think
I know like I know Bo brother Fabio it's
like a rotting body bro it was bad dude
- my monkey my body run a wreck I don't
know she she was to hit something once
and it was all over bumper I love her
tyres and they stuck but this [ __ ] was
worse dude he said the inner he said I
had a lot of fat ladies in the car but I
wonder what would have a big old fat
lady in the world nowhere no more
because they don't fit so she has to be
a big old lady like their lady and was
Eating Gilbert Grape
Oh some disdain and and then she just
like she couldn't she saw that underwear
on and she sat there with her dress or
something that I think a lady would wear
some underwear I don't think it's that I
think it's something that decomposing in
there if you said it smelled like food
and some and [ __ ] or whatever dude she
could've but right now it's big it's
true to my stomach and central juvenile
hall there was a speaking of family
there was a big she had 3 bananas in a
bag that were behind a refrigerator and
that was there's like it's always some
little thing the reason I found it
because fleas were flies or coming out
yeah it's like fermenting cuz if it's
fruit or anything it'll ferment and it
smell a little bit of like alcohol car
nothing was trapped in a corner
underneath in the trunk
somebody stuff something in his seat
probably did oh man if I was driving
lungs and I was going I felt like
getting off I feel like I still I give
up five stars
she gave him off a breeze bottle I don't
know mr. niver nice every made it worse
- it was just like I would have been a
fresh male with a decomposing body
I because I I am our neighbor died a
long time ago like mr. Hyde
when I was living in the projects Pecola
Lisa
living there with my eggs my son and I'm
their mom and their brother and I'm at
least we just artists money like bro
like first [ __ ] you know like but then
it just kind of strong bro there was
just bad and his body was think about it
decomposing it's brutal man they clean
the rubber little pipes up family moved
they're like no problem
throw some bleach on that [ __ ] see
that's a job right there like people say
all there's no jobs that we can't find a
job there is jobs but you gotta [ __ ]
could be a cleaner like any person that
cleans a murder scene or goes in there
after a dirty ass [ __ ] family and a
dirty dog sure the whole place or or
like ember when I told you that how
first house I owned the main line broke
under the toilet and we didn't even know
it so I started smelling some
decomposition I I was like something's
dead there's a rat or something dead
so then I thought maybe there's
something wrong with the plumbing and I
flushed the toilet and I went and looked
under the crawlspace just right into the
ground under the cross pool it's like
right under the toilet just landed
everything I affirmed for maybe a week
and I didn't know what to do I called
these plumbers who had worked on the
house earlier and I was like maybe they
like crack the pipe or something don't
feel like they know what that was about
I still feel like they did but anyway oh
but we have a recommendation of these
people who can help clean up this
problem who would that Judith affect you
so these guys show up so these guys show
up coming up my driveway so good they're
these Tongan imagine Felipe with a big
ol afro but like hazmat suits on these
Tongan brothers still toes came in and
clean that [ __ ] up here in the soil I
don't even know man they dug all that
stuff out they took that took it away
hauled it away and then they turned the
soil and then they put like four fans
down there and some deodorizing like
crystals or something or the top it was
I think I had to air out for like three
or four days that's what it was
after that they fix the pipe and but
they had a recommendation this plumbing
company no I mean but they you know they
had somebody else's palm they were
greasing and I felt like it was a Roth
IRA Proctor yeah
this guy says they make you give a
special certificate and degrees for
those type of freaking job certificate
for the poison you work with don't you
really heard that bicep bro that guy at
Home Depot to just work in the yard and
he just thought I could eat grass and
then I forgot a bunch of blister hit his
both hands big jump oh yes right and
then Willie was like degrading that guy
other way to save out to buy a lotion
funny one xwb party right but he hire
you hire someone to do your work
and he get infected well whatever it
wasn't his ground game on that boy yes
it probably it was a rash like some
poison ivy or some three came with a
broke cuz I hope that will clean out his
backyard he gave me 50 bucks ready with
a spot huh not even to see that I went
to the Irvine no it was a Ontario improv
I went to collect [ __ ] signatures for
this fool for two days straight I didn't
get a guest spot bro next time bro see
right now bro you up the stage where
you're learning bro here to give you a
2003 so you're sitting there dude I was
walking the mall you got nothing nothing
hurts me in 2003 you don't even know
what that means who nobody but I have no
idea
he gave him the gene are the kids I
don't know what he did with Richard jad
a little bit after that's when Richard
started working with them
hey but he reminds me of those Mexicans
@ej that are all against the caravan the
Hondurans and all that [ __ ] did you see
the main one that's against to care
about a TJ like the white looking German
Mexican [ __ ] office job Mexican what
so of these they're paid I think they
have nothing better to do they're poor
people [ __ ] with poor people that's
it there'll be a dick to pee it's not
the government doing it okay but yeah
yep those against all that [ __ ] and
those fools are giving people that have
like [ __ ] up feet from walking [ __ ]
mouth I know people acting like these
are an armed Caravan or so there are no
shoes how are you invasion like what I
mean okay a soft invasion yeah this is
agent require artillery gun I almost
watch that vice thing I haven't watched
it yet what's a quick snip yeah which
one it's like the caravan coming Spanish
Caravan yes I know you can think about
it dude all those Mexicans talking [ __ ]
what tribes doing over here then you
know there's only a small group of
people that's not like it's everybody
but they highlighted on places like Fox
News and stuff and then an umbrella it
emboldened the people here who want who
don't want this caravan coming and they
say see even they don't want them in
their country yeah so it's like into a
map Voltron were in the Toledo there's a
comedian on Instagram there was that's
all you highlights
he's like a right-winger like pro-trump
guy he's all look at these Mexicans
that's us in our own country moving what
is the Nationalists has to stand for
something
you know those Haitians I saw the other
people saw a lot of the people that were
complete well someone approached it look
like cholo they were deported there were
there like against immigrants that are
going
trying to get into a place they kick yo
ass out for being a [ __ ] stupid chola
way they're all mad because they might
get in yeah a lot of people were against
the cameramen see what I saw wait a
minute he's like a damn shoulder for
Whittier yeah taking my spot a party I'm
the only one I want to sweep restaurants
here yeah I have a distant relative that
was uh that wasn't born in the US he was
born in Mexico he came over he was cholo
did a bunch of dirt and I was living a
DJ your brother probably knows I'm done
no we are still taking donations for
Angel
Felipe's brother if you want in there
leaves
yeah double X shirts I always wonder why
it wasn't there a service dude they're
like if you didn't get faces across the
border right you like get their hair cut
right not like a bicycle clothes I think
you know sound like a dad answer me
because you don't even oh well sure I
will watch that show bro it's like okay
you can't come in here looking like you
shoot darts out of a straw you have to
blend in more like back then like a
little oppa had that haircut bro you can
be coming into America wearing a [ __ ]
Julius Caesar haircut
well if you look looking at dirty George
W Bush had this friend Alberto Gonzales
become the Attorney General if you look
if you gave him a [ __ ] up haircut and
dirty shoes he would look like he was in
the caravan but he's off cleaned up a
nice little suit hair all [ __ ]
jet-black died you know he blend into
the other one kind of like what she
stood for those guys say he was teaching
them how to be American shoutouts
these are otm or other there
yeah man that was the best costume we
saw this Oh
sorry was that Monica these for agent
for Asian guys were dressed like a
[ __ ] am so bored is too late
Chinese guys they're walking like
exactly like though other than Mexicans
my board is today and I would like the
[ __ ] Dodger had yeah man it's crazy
man I just like those are like melting
pot like you know what's the word
assimilation techniques the surface
similar assimilation into Chicano
culture that was Ronald Reagan I'm
little little all those Cubans in you
know if it's out Castro there were
everywhere bro I didn't know that I'm
even the reason that our Cubans came to
California was because they just had too
many in Miami so they were sending more
everywhere well they couldn't do nothing
all the Cubans were established it had
to go up to New York and go to the south
there's a bunch of Cuban families in
Riverside so I chucked my nose are timid
one time right I know people give them
tubing over here lot Messier PG give me
neither his I don't they brought him
over here because they had too many
basically the mayor of Miami right yeah
said we have too many and they tried to
find other cities that would take up and
that's where Echo Park got their
population of Cubans will choke the
people yeah I know how many Cubans are
left over there anymore
just that one leader that's pissed off
it but that guy that was a restaurant
and there Porto's I say I said well you
their portraits or Martino
that's a woman that complains about
Obama raising the price of sugar it's
funny every any Latino business that
gets a successful everybody says that
fools a thief he never played his
employees he steals they always hate
success come scrutinize everything good
job it's a job creator
I wish Luis lived closer he could be on
the show more so what'd you guys do for
Thanksgiving we're going tomorrow stay
away from family we don't want to go to
anybody's family
anyways house so we go tomorrow babe we
went there the last couple years and
with kayak and stuff like that and
there's this little apartment we stay in
little condo as a full kitchen so I'll
make food there who watch The Twilight
Zone marathon and play games in our
pajamas that's what I'm looking forward
to you're off for two weeks in a row for
the first time like since February maybe
yeah man March I think you've had two
weeks oh I do the tofurkey yeah probably
the Gardein one I like yeah stuffing
inside Bobby was a leg kick to the stand
the only thing I haven't had as far as
Thanksgiving goes as far as a bird is a
deep-fried turkey or a tour or a turd
Duncan dog track in well so with other
are these our friends friends giving a
lot of friends giving so there it's race
given let me tell my family anybody
anybody invited me to a friend's game it
means that they're wondering if I'm
which was a regular Thanksgiving dinner
on Thursday
[ __ ] that that's we go oh so you didn't
invite me for Thanksgiving on a [ __ ]
Monday but not a [ __ ] Thursday where
everybody's there
[ __ ] you I want you're not my [ __ ]
friend I thought you know [ __ ] your
friends giving my friends my colleagues
in another both snapchat they're having
these big
yeah man you go home you go home too
easy Amazon are you real picky bro we
don't have [ __ ] champagne Shelley had
clear books what are the first
Thanksgiving I went to in New York we
didn't know anybody at all and my ex he
had a woman at work who invited us to
her thing she was having a friendsgiving
thing so we went over there and it was
like Martha Stewart style she had a
pumpkin shell with pumpkin soup in it
and like it was it was super fancy and I
didn't even take the price tag off my
$2.00 wine for me to say this but I
remember I'm doing great we made up on
placemats out of out of paper mache
paper and [ __ ] and I brought it home and
I try to put it under my under my team
to eat and my dad ripped it felt like
boy felt like we're now in Bad Santa he
[ __ ] ate all the chocolates out of
the bucket calendar and it really put
[ __ ] cough drops just having a bad
day you know was he drunk
No stone-cold sober it was it took
forever we made a button we made a bunch
of after great we bunch a bunch of um
Thanksgiving um little while whatever
placemats placemats but it was like um
it was like we we don't know we do
interwined we've we the whole thing with
different colors turkey on the side body
whole took it out rotor sport how does
she like chicken kebab a little better
it threw his dog [ __ ] if I said it so
sad see one of those courses would've
been good for him don't this is a
placemat for
so everything is given as you do a coke
bump after that make you forget I knew I
heard that moment Thanksgivings gonna be
tough so I would just get [ __ ] up bro
like I don't know why but like like the
Wednesday before things game and I will
get so [ __ ] up that something just
like be all hung over that you'll go
anywhere so when I met you dude you're a
sober what would he do those years when
you weren't [ __ ] because you weren't
even smoking weed for those no I'll go
home with mommy sad bro yeah after that
before that I remember bro I bet you in
the carry be well one time I went to
mondo the house with Dan that was a year
I met you guys another time I went to UM
with Joe Diaz and maybe had more friends
like I'm Rick go Rick Ramos and Millie
Martinez and we violated David yeah how
you guys called me that day Jordi
Hurtado bring some weed
now we're away yeah it was fun Oh
another time I don't know we have a
taste giving my brother Albert was
dating his Cuban girl I don't know we
talked about it last time but she was
dating a Cuban girl and they were living
over there by my Widmer Widmer area over
there by a look through the lucas area
where he used to live and his sad roses
like the mom she had a chair like she
took in fosters oh those people use to
get fosters from jeweler ha they were
like these kids but there are Tolos and
they were doing all the work she need
money for the holidays bro there are so
many places for kids famously she
started
homeboy industry bro
they were these [ __ ] killer ass
cholos and like no youngsters right but
they were journalists you know and I'm
there with my hood there was like the
first time that uh my whole family was
there except my dad you know my mom and
dad we're not talking but everybody was
there in
Joe Fernando Juan Carlos Albert Marcia
me Rafa my mom my brother's girlfriend
her mom and the [ __ ] endangered
service bro so so well everything was
good but start noticing cuz everybody
was fat kind of fat in a family too
they put no salt on anything bro what's
up with fat people that oh you saw maybe
they had a high blood me so far you do
like my sister was clot was Turner like
Loki cloud that house low my system
chatter Loki crowd their house they
every was Josie like a 40s corner bro
he's faded by that laughs eat there now
like my brother's girlfriend ask for a
loaf bread a dinner roll please and my
sister instead of gravity with a hat she
stabbed me with a fork and they put on
top of the cat doors you like an
American Thanksgiving turkey stuffing
gravy everything rolls
no but everything was like it was like
bad yeah so there was no started pepper
too I saw my mom to open up her purse
and she should do a lot of peppers
honestly do not share it bro you brought
it there's only enough for you having a
good time and this is where that lady
made all of us go around and tell us why
we're
oh my god oh that was what I was gonna
say in that New York thing they made us
go around and tell them why we're
thankful pop quiz
like sitting there trying to think of
something stupid I don't know these
people I know anybody's name at this
table I was right
I know like new friends what am I
supposed to say what did you say did you
say something
oh did you say something well I'm happy
we're out here whatever but then my
mouths are doing a long speech and we
were like in Spanish yeah she was just a
- you know a speech about it out you
know she's in a speech bro like it she's
like it sounded more like a burst of
steam to myself that she just trying to
act that she made all this possible cuz
she started thanking everybody goes you
know my family we're never together and
I'm glad that everybody is here and I
got I got deeper deeper got real then I
got into him we got close to like
Stewart sabers family bro my brother and
I later on and I broke were later
laughing about that speech I felt bad
that didn't feel bad give it up forever
Perot we're all there right and then
they made a bunch of cakes bro
strawberry cakes banana cake [ __ ] pie
apple pie all made by the cholos those
foods provided in there baby
and he goes hey I need a knife and then
I bet it was a Loki banner those cholos
- bro I brought my family with bad dude
then I said I still a joke caravan I
said a joke about our I don't know I
said Oh Joe came to stay at the air man
I adopted one of those kids with 12
cents a day then everybody roll because
those guys are old friends you know
their Fosters - it was a bad joke to say
at the table but I know those kind of
look back Rowley because I heard faster
and they were washing dishes bro over 18
cake and having coffee they were washing
dishes they didn't get facility never
sat down with us they never were they
like teenagers 14 16
tough man that's the foster-care place a
bit surprised those kids gonna stab them
in the middle of the night I'm sure it's
happened
the only push a human so far faster kids
get treated like [ __ ] but I didn't know
what's going on man you know I would
like I don't know who they were
nobody said to me okay we're gonna be
getting over here by the link was here
don't dress like Butler's raining you
were wearing a handkerchief grow it with
a blue one yeah man but they're both
when they brought the cake my sister
said like anything everybody heard it
I hope this cake has sugar egg cuz I
don't know circuit packets and yeah it
was chic it was ballistic a can't
[ __ ] show them around the sugar was
really was [ __ ] Emily was sweet at
not having stomach that case we are
[ __ ] all right but it was like a crazy
event but that was no good things given
but then but other things giving man
we're a time we were at my mom's house
and my brother my wife my my my
girlfriend was praying it fit of mom she
was pregnant but she was big and she
wasn't really a big girl to begin with
bro I don't like a bigger just to show
up they showed up on my lap they land on
your life you gotta take she broke that
femur in three places so she was big
you Chilean she was pregnant she's
pregnant bro like let's [ __ ] yeah
they're like I'm like fresh out of rehab
I don't know how to react to she'd be
that pregnant
Philip was born in July first exactly
we're gonna get to that right so we're
at the dinner table right everybody's
there she's like three months
[Laughter]
to be celebrated more with the black guy
so where's the dinner table right the
kid was born already know the kid was
born okay so three months after he was
so we're like Chile right my brother
sitting right here right my brother
Fernando yeah my brother angel over here
feigning you know so I have people for
money or just looking at what could
borrow and everybody's there all chillin
and my dad in the corner whatever I'm
looking at his ass right deal about my
place mat for the 15th year in a row
look at him man like I was just thinking
because my mom brought it my MA she my
mom actually brought a placemat there
for like tearing that man just this
piece of [ __ ] right here
well anyway so we're sitting down man
and then we're eating Asian and then I'm
my mom goes over part of the trick he go
I think what a little a little breast
and then um she looked over at my son
mom well part of the circuit if she
wants my brother said all of it
everybody died brother laughing like
[ __ ] it up James Gandolfini when he came
out of the hospital and I was laughing
and he didn't get it like he was just
eyeballing everybody in slow motion and
I say that's funny yeah that's funny
fool I [ __ ] I [ __ ] push my brother
real fast so fast all you heard was and
then like though his face got red and
tears came out bro
and a my dad didn't see it right but my
dad picked up his plate and slammed it
she closed and then I said I'm let years
ago before [ __ ] everybody up in here and
then like and therefore the mom didn't
um she made it worse brother we have an
aide who emanates a fright when that
guy's pallulah whatever they was in
Goodfellas showed up with his [ __ ]
girlfriend with that white fur coat and
then he didn't it didn't they they wrote
the never loosing him [ __ ] then he
pushed her out the door the [ __ ] is
taking that [ __ ] solo on the wheel get
the [ __ ] out I just said let's just get
the [ __ ] out of here
we are what she said I we have an eight
laughing again all right well you
protected her honor I think what a
gentleman will do but you got it like
give those credit I know man he told me
that when this [ __ ] happens to you it's
not that funny but you gotta take him
how you give him down he told me that
story when I first met him I said that's
so funny and he was like I know he said
I know it's funny but you know when
you're with me like I have your back or
whatever she didn't even know you had
her back she's oblivious to it right
don't know damn imagine the laughs you
guys could have had if it were like
sitting there on the floor dog be
building up an appetite to eat because
you [ __ ] war yourself out [ __ ]
cackles that's funny man but it's okay
bro I had a good laugh after we broke up
and now him no no I heard we broke up
and I'm [ __ ] when we last moved on bro
and my brother had kids and then it was
- Bucky
nice his birthday blow up Dana she was
twenty four or five and then my little
brother oh my god oh he's been
practicing my brother was like a fat kid
bro from Bad Santa bro that [ __ ]
was practicing it's a small world to run
different wonderful world by up Louie
Armstrong I see flowers in the spring so
my little brother practice E but we
didn't know why we don't know why I
thought you were just practicing you
know and then I just keep going up you
know I wasn't no I don't even know if I
was living there but I was like I was I
was like living alone
back then already so I was like I went
to the party and I don't know what's
going on but um fool that fool breaks up
the whole party and to say that he wants
to sing her a song and Friday everybody
dog fool to tell you about my sister
well I saw my sister run in the house oh
my god she was dying bro laughing - bro
I would love an extra heart bro - Oh
business anymore it was party dude
because everybody went in there except
my brothers go for the time family bro
why your mom left - oh my god so they
didn't stick around to hear him sing it
all that's so sad different end no but
it was like they play they play the song
and it like it staticky and in a mighty
like eating eating practice at a
microphone you know so let her I see
flowers in the spring
[Laughter]
for this Thanksgiving but that's fine
that's his placemat story his placement
story when he tells his Thanksgiving
story that's it was it Thanksgiving yeah
no the birthday party a party man oh my
god could have stopped laughing I was
hurtful but I was painful to watch it
felt like a part of my limb without fire
ago but the way my sister ran in because
she also she read in she was crying but
crying because she felt bad but also
laugh be real loud cause you thought
ridiculous full of emotion bro he
probably got that idea from some TV show
or something you know to do that like
you know like a sitcom and ends and a
happy ending you know and somebody sings
a song or something and he probably saw
that and wanted to recreate it you guys
we're not playing along you're the
family that and go for that yeah I'm
surprised that I started doing stand-up
comedy because I pretty sure if I would
have told them I'd wear a Donnybrook and
sometime to do alone but I told my dad I
go but yeah man that was hard though
that uh it's a wonderful life song
wonderful world it's a wonderful world a
little fat fool coming in America he
would look like him too he dressed up a
brother angels like they're probably all
cracked how he was doing this bonus time
because he he
it each other beat Neil Armstrong but no
way got that joke either bro so you
should be up this thing you were there
me yeah that was Emad he never tried to
sing again or look ugh
I have no idea but he went to cupcakes
after that but that's more like he's the
one who didn't go to alcohol and drugs
he went to cupcakes yeah they they
laughter you hope everybody laughed at
your brother no I just need like I told
you that the mouse came over for the
first time and that fool played him that
[ __ ] red-hot tape that's it that's
about it man just laughing at each other
and [ __ ]
have you seen your brother in a while I
seen him two weeks ago does he live
there still yeah please make it as far
as a family ghost I would love to have
Marcia on one time but I don't know what
she I don't know if she feels
comfortable party man I was I think you
reminded her that story she didn't
remember it into Marcia
I don't know I think she didn't remember
like running away or something like that
it's just like huh
and you had to refresh her memory she's
like oh you know I kind of remembered
that so it was something that you for
you like yeah [ __ ] movie that's
replayed and when you're doing that
actor if you don't tell me you dig my
feet tell me about some [ __ ] I do not
remember but then I remember vividly
other things mostly so you let them um
you left a print in that person liable
that's far too bad right but what's the
stamp or somebody reused
what's up fool you ever help you you
were like I don't like going into like
Thanksgiving I like to get there early
sometimes you know but I don't really
like to help me no way to help well at
your family I hope you cleaned up
they'll know your family's house you
don't help I help with cleanup we
haven't had a family haven't been to
your fan I don't have any family here
but you don't have you haven't been to a
family thing in six years I think since
the bond since the Badgers insted
incident since the Dodgers birthday
incident yeah my [ __ ] I'm new it's a
wonderful world didn't want to didn't
get invited to a bucket didn't complaint
getting by it to a baseball game all the
dog again yeah they talk [ __ ] to me and
then I said you're an idiot
and I lose my number I don't want to
ever talk to you the kid he's talking
[ __ ] to me and he said I hope I'm
invited to the wedding still you didn't
invite me to this and you know what he
didn't he wasn't invited to the way I
think [ __ ] you and then ever since then
then his other brother jumped into it
with me like I don't know why you're
here this doesn't involve you just get
out of this and then Felipe's like fine
we're never gonna so we just hang out
with like Fernando sometimes and his mom
sometimes and Marsha sometimes and
that's in Albert sometimes I will drop I
would jump out of the flew like like if
we're in the area or remember one time I
just went through with Benny and I ran
and Rudy was already in there and we
don't always make of food one time man
but they had a barbecue the day before
so there were so many leftovers beans
and double two liters half of a pie like
that just make a little [ __ ] fees but
my mom what what time where we have fish
share a bunch of fish that was already
cooked so she provided and we're
currently leftover carne asada you know
I should we had our surf and turf
we are carne asada fish was of each
other ceviche
no placemats yeah the other brother got
so self-righteous I just couldn't
oh my older brother bro [ __ ] radio
Raheem a fall harvest my brother Asia is
so [ __ ] up that he will call my other
brother Radio Raheem because I'm through
the right thing never read or write he
died last year yeah my brother have been
radio laude my brothers had the same
commando haircut at what time we got
radio Raheem a he ready bro dark
complexion be cheaper yet Dori will tell
you adopted well that fool got all
self-righteous one time talking about
we're having we're gonna have a well
they're gonna have Thanksgiving dinner
at somebody's house his house but he
didn't saying Thanksgiving now because
they took one one course of Chicano
Studies need to colonize now and leaving
the Pasadena and [ __ ] they [ __ ]
so we're gonna have the great harvest
dinner and I'm like ah neuropathy I want
to go to that yeah I don't want to
reminisce my place man
that's the problem smell see I was gonna
say that when I was good in there when
you when you were saying that when
something's pivotal for somebody like
that they remember everything about it
and then other people don't remember
that situation they were there too but
when you confront a parent about
something that is something that you've
dealt with for years and held on to for
years and you finally bring it up to
your parents and they say I don't
remember Miss Huckabee and it's like
[ __ ] this has been in my head
for 25 years and I'm finally confronting
you about it you don't remember or my
mom well you know I'm sorry I picked the
wrong dad for you guys
should give excuses it made her look
good I picked the wrong guy to be your
dad or whatever to have kids with that's
only works if you let that bro yeah I
know you [ __ ] the wrong guy without
protection but anyway but it she would
she would she wouldn't remember your mom
said the same thing when you talked to
her but that other stuff that became
your joke that thing you talk to you
confronted her about it she's like I
don't remember and that is the worst
pain when they don't remember it you
know cuz then you realize [ __ ] I held on
to this [ __ ] for all this you are but
how can you not when it hits you so
emotionally during that moment you know
and it's not resolved at the time ah it
is frustrating it's like it's like it
invalidates all your feelings for all
those years thinking about a man about
the place man unless it's just it was
best to have it with my dad and I didn't
give a [ __ ] I guess that's why bro there
was like a shootout or a big fight and
my dad ran everybody runs to go see the
cheese man like to see what's going on
but my dad my dad died he was slaying
row here bought these shoes and at a
yard sale so they were nice color with
her bowling shoes but then I didn't know
didn't matter where I'm everywhere bro
there's no attraction little trashy he
didn't know bro everybody ran dude a
little bit of wet fur or more popped up
over the line
I was laughing bro like um it's a
wonderful world right slick guy your way
Fiji puto
yeah mo ready
I want you to make placemats for this
holiday put plates on my lap now war
plates an hour and something five
minutes you know it's funny man like so
we were taught that we went to a
Christmas one time and my mom's house
and then my mom was acting like Miguel
Feliz Tatiana go of the [ __ ] art the
Mexican narcos like um she pretty money
my mom should I have a cocaine scale
right there bro for that [ __ ] my son
like she knew they were too heavy or
there was too much meat she will start
all over again like they all had to be a
certain place like she had a like a
little system going
well yeah what's the first time I was
little like tamales rule I know I like a
lot of massa
I like a big fat tamale I don't care
about the filling but I like a lot of
massa but she's we're it's like a
factory like an assembly line right so
we're all sitting there doing it and
after each one that I made she comes
over and picks it up don't piss out do
heavy too heavy and then she'll send it
back to the front of the hall to get
scraped out and then eventually I got
pushed out of the line
well the assembly line but it was they
were too but she made little tiny ones
though like the ones that they sell at
Wiener schnitzel they they advertised
that was so gross
little tiny cigar looking one yeah man
your mom skimps on that stuff I know man
like I was watching and some people make
tamales and I get my mom now I know now
I know why they added so much talking I
guess we were not that rich so you can
put that much meat so I'm gonna put meat
[ __ ] your potatoes jalapeno sometimes
Kara's bro I like can't you just put
meeting don't don't [ __ ] up or no
carrots in there open up you know what
to start that plastic they know stop
with a [ __ ] olive with a seed inside
man
with the seed in there yeah I'm I will
put the Olly with the CD yeah what watch
a resort lady or we're selling our
pumpkin spice tamales bro pumpkin pie
tomorrow thank you bite the money enough
Oh deal enough for the [ __ ] pie
Somalis well that's a 2018 tamale lady
cop it's weird-looking who would want to
put ice cream on that sheet I would feel
like if you mix the pumpkin with some
masa it's too wet to actually get firm
like a tamale you know I would think
there's already pumpkin pie right well
that to see didn't she I don't think I
like sweet tamales I think that's my
problem because I had to pineapple was
talking about chili relleno what's it
called uh oh no God or something like
that no no it's part of Mexico now is
very trained Ivan's mom made it
oh my god white cream yeah and a palm
and a pomegranate seasonal all right I
admit I miss mommy at the Myra with
pomegranate seeds inside and a
helicopter all men being over it brother
no cream it's all right seasonal popular
the best tamales ever had is that big
dogs houseful woody Barcena yeah the mom
put two rods and cheese in there good -
they were really good
I like 2000 until he got mad brother you
know tamales where's the tamales that
I'm sorry bro what do you want me to do
now [ __ ] my mom only makes so many
she only makes like two parts and that's
a dog people people people say that to
my lady are good but the tamales Kim's -
bro
yeah but the tamale new lady will you
know what the street tamales what I've
noticed they use a lot of the fatty meat
a lot of like it's not really like
they're really good cuz they're faster
you know they taste real good cuz the
fat but it's not the best cuts of meat
well I watched it after me Bourdain um
episode I think they were either
in Cuba or some other Latino country and
bro they really like the tamales tamales
old-school way like they use the fat of
they were doing they were cooking the
meat they put it over so much right oh
yeah the foremost meat and fat they use
that water and pork grease up for the
tamale mixture the Cubans do it like
that
Caribbean people do it how can you kind
of like that again I never used like
them but I tasted in Mexico like those
actually wrap tamales yeah I well I kind
of do but I think I prefer the one with
the corn husk I like the dryer and this
is kind of similar yeah like there okay
I did like them for a while but I think
I really prefer the Mexican style my
friend somali are the ones you eat three
days later and you fry up I am coffee
dip cream that's funny the only time I
eat tamales with beans when I fry it's a
good mix right oh hell yeah oh that's
what we're gonna say and I'm in some
little last town in Mexico and like a
hipster hipster area of Mexico a bunch
of like rich Mexican hipsters dresses
they're eating up yeah shifters it's a
big thing now to put up it's called a
torta tamale they get a regular torta
like a torta prayer they open it up and
they put a whole tamale inside with
beans and all that that's so much bread
but that's just you know what if you're
at jeweler morning yeah you're [ __ ]
buzz do you want to eat something warm
and something delicious it's gonna help
feel your mouth a bunch of flavors
that's the [ __ ] thought I want I
thought that a mile without yeah that's
like that Czechoslovakian thing we saw
on Anthony Bourdain show that was a
[ __ ] good estar my life before they
paid a dollar for it yeah it was that
bread it was like late-night food and a
big ol like fried cheese thing covered
in bread it was just like a ball of
fried cheese breaded and if
put it on a bun with mustard on a bread
and then I smashed its like Reggie
Bailey's dressing it was like a patty of
cheese and he did put in a bread he bit
it bruh you know the cheese came down he
says I live for ya this the morning a
beer yeah it's like street food it looks
so good
what's up full I give this show a plus
if I should give this show higher than
an A+ I will give it a higher than A+
Thanksgiving what's up for everybody
happy Thanksgiving listen man I know
you're a comedian and if you're a person
who live in Los Angeles somewhere you
know anybody anywhere anywhere anywhere
and you have nowhere to go
nobody to eat you want to go to a cool
place to hang out on hang out at and if
you're a podcast listener looking for
something fun to do go to the Laugh
Factory on Thanksgiving there's gonna be
like four shows and they feed everybody
bro there's Thanksgiving dinner you're
gonna see Dean cook he's backed by the
breasts and Thanksgiving pumpkin pie
free dinner for everybody
comedy show a lot of Legends show up
like Kevin Nealon some homeless show up
but it's not just for the whole
community if you were to stand in line
also the Laugh Factory also man if you
wanna volunteer with this help come on
down man and you look for Jamie Masada
I tell you want to see what song he'll
say nobody get in the back of those
everybody's man thank you very much but
I'm thankful for our listeners who've
been wizards in the beginning I'll shut
up to the guy right here come a [ __ ] to
work her mic here whatever your name is
come on come on come on come on Camilla
goes Alice this guy right here dead some
deep Juan Vargas Llosa one Vargas is a
regular Alex DeLarge didn't show up
Jermaine Mario showed up yeah German ISM
or whatever his name is on here and
shout-out to all those people that came
from Toronto to Buffalo to see me
there's somebody I'm from Germany
Ching I can't go wiedersehen he checked
in earlier I can't see his name anymore
all these common Eider know how you can
watch him later okay good I was gonna go
to the chat
you got a replay Live Chat and it'll
play it happy Thanksgiving happy
Thanksgiving everybody all right my
brother says great harvest make memories
people happy Chinese people would be
appreciative of everybody and if your
son made an art project oh really
coke addict you'll be a coke added in a
comedian I've gotta let that [ __ ] out
that's a tough one for you